student tell us about online algorithms
for convex objectives so I'm going to
speak about some general natural
generalization of the what is known as
the primal online primal dual framework
and I know it's very natural because
three different groups of people thought
and wrote papers on this on several
aspects of this extension or
generalization so many of the quarters
are around here so if you have a
difficult question just pick the closest
one and ask the question so so so the
plan is I will have to tell you briefly
what is the online primal dual framework
so this is repeated from previous talks
that I gave then I will tell you about
this natural extension of the primal
problem and then i will say where is the
dual is also a natural extension and
they will both studied for special cases
then i will tell you whether the main
result for this that we have and
hopefully some of the algorithms that
are really really simple and some of the
analysis ideas that are also quite
simple i think so so the starting point
of the flame okafor online primal dual
is just what is known as a covering
packing framework so this is just the
the primal problem is a covering problem
so this is the general LP except with
all the coefficients he also acts out
the variables where of dimension n you
know in the talk and then all the
coefficient of a a i j and see this is
the transpose when i put prime are all
non-negative so so this is a covering
problem and this covering problem has a
dual problem which is a packing problem
again this a is the same a this is the
same see and you have a dual variable
for each whole Hill and what is known is
that each primal solution the value of
each payment solution is more than the
value of each dual solution so we can
lower bound them and strong duality say
that the optimal solution is equal so
this is although it doesn't capture all
of the offline problems it captured
quite a lot so so all relaxations of set
cover facility location connectivity
Steiner tree for West shortest paths and
even paging you can capture with the
covering constraints packing also very
useful so all of the knapsack flow
problems matching like combinatorial
options so all of these are captured can
be captured with the just packing
constraints so now over this primal dual
tell I put some online framework so what
is the online framework so look at the
covering so the number of 40 is d that I
used for time and sometimes for
transpose so at any time you get to know
the the next role of the next constraint
the next covering constraint and this
corresponding the dual to a new dual
variable and now the problem is that you
have variables x j so you can only
increase them but never the crease the
the values and then what you want is to
minimize the total cost this is the
online covering problem and the dual
problem of the packing is that whenever
you get to know a new dual constraint
and all all of its coefficient you just
need to set its value immediately and
then later on you are not allowed to
touch it anymore and you want to
maximize profit so i will show you two
examples that i will generalize later so
one candidate problem is just the online
set cover so what is online set cover
you have a ground set of elements II and
and some sets em sets with
of this ground set but then you get to
know the elements one by one so you get
each element and whenever an element
arrives you have to just choose some set
to cover it and later on you cannot
unchoose some set and you just want to
minimize the total cost so you can see
that the relaxation of this problem is
captured nicely with this framework
because you want to minimize the number
of sets with your taking excess is just
taking the set and these are covering
constraints you want you must cover each
element and whenever an element arrives
you just to get to know additional
covering constraints because a
constraint okay so this is a an example
for covering problem what is packing so
I chose to a virtual circuit routing
just remove the routing which is not so
important and so what is the virtual
circuit routing you have a graph you
have capacities on the edges siiii and
then at each time you get a request
which is just the source now the target
node and most important the path between
SI and TI you can also live with without
a certain path but this makes the LP
nicer and then what you should decide is
at at this point you should either
accept the request and give capacity of
one for this request or reject it and
and later on you cannot change your mind
and what you want is to maximize the
number of requests accepted and you can
see that this can be written as a as a
backing problem so why are I is
accepting requests ow we could request
our I and then the number of requests
that are using
an edge e is that Morsi and the online
process here is that you get new dual
variables which correspond to new
requests you need to set them
immediately and later on you cannot
change your mind so these are two two
examples and then this this frame will
capture many many problems so many
problems like online set cover online
connectivity metrical task system paging
the packing capture matching problems
and and this routing and even online
combinatorial options that i will show
you in a few slides so what is known so
the problem is almost closed i will say
in a minute why i think every still
something to work on so the existent
algorithm that produce solution x and y
feasible solutions x is order of log D
competitive these the sparsity of the
matrix a so it's the maximal number of
nonzero entries in each hole of a the
packing you can get log D but also plus
log a max to a min a max and a mean is
the maximal to minimal nonzero entry in
each column of a and it is known that
both these results are tight
asymptotically so the simple example
that show these are tight so what is the
natural generalization Viteri groups
walked on so it's really natural you
take the primal which is linear then you
can think about what happens if you want
to minimize some nonlinear function f of
X right very very natural and you can
think about f-first as monotone
functions so the cost of some if X is
less than Y then the cost of f of X is
less than F of Y so this capture for
example that these are non-negative and
f might be a convex function this makes
the problem at least offline
polynomially solvable so so very very
natural extension I will speak in a
minute on applications and then the
online process is again hope survive one
at a time and then just you can just
increase variables as as you go so here
is here is an example of generalization
of the online set cover before so you
can think about what we call LP norm set
cover well you have like k cost function
so CI is now vector it's a you have K
cost function little non-negative and
then we want to minimize the LP gnome
this is the LP nom to the P of these
cost functions so again elements arrive
just the cost function is changed it is
now a nonlinear so so if you take for
example p equal one you just get back to
the original framework of cost for each
set here because it's just the sum of
linear functions but you can think for
example of trying to minimize the
maximum among this add several different
objective functions this much maximum is
captured by if you take p equal roughly
tool okay then approximate this maximum
and the motivation of such problem can
be coming from combining multiple
objective may expand which is the
minimizing the maximum maybe energy so P
doesn't have to be it can be even
fractional larger than 1 so many people
consider the such nonlinear objectives
so this is the one example but what is
nice about the primal dual problem is
that you get to solve two problems in
one shot this is really nice and this
problem has a dual problem that is also
very
natural so when you write the dual of
this problem you no longer a linear dual
so we get what is known as fenchel dwell
so the ventured well you have again
variable for each hole here so you want
to maximize the sum of YT but minus what
is known as the conjugate function or
the fenchel dual function of eight now
this is transpose Y and this fenchel I
will show in a minute why wit duality is
quite trivial is this function it's a
super moon over all X fatal larger than
zero of this of this thing which is
always convex because it's a supermom of
affine functions but moreville if the
function is nice if the function f is
nice what is nice it's continuous convex
monotone like like our the functions
that we work on add vegetable then also
you can think about the f star is as a
nice function it's also convex its
monotone non-negative and again if you
apply again f style next hour we'll get
to Beth 22 F so so just to give you some
intuition and I don't have a lot of
information for this I will prove weak
duality which is three lines so so here
is a profit if you have two solutions
feasible solutions x and y then this
objective is more than this objective
always so so f of x is trivially larger
than f of x times y transpose ax minus y
why because X is feasible so ax minus 1
this is non-negative and this is also
non-negative right then I just make some
changing in how I write things I put
away the some affair YT here and then
instead of this i just write the
supermoon
and this is ok because x is greater than
zero by the feasibility of X and this is
the definition of differential duel and
and actually in our work we only use
weak duality although a strong duality
also in many cases hold so so again in
this talk you should just think of f
star is a nice function some other nice
function ok so so what is the extension
of the dwell and I will give an example
in a minute again primal constraints
arrive so you have a new dual that
arrived at each time now you should set
YT immediately to some value and you
earn this value of YT but you pay some
cost of this function all right so so
you'll have some some cost with you pay
and you want to maximize the amount of
perfect way to get minus the cost fatter
or that you have so so here is an
example of virtual circuit routing but
now you can buy capacity so so it's
again you have requests as before you
can accept request or reject the request
but the capacity is not something that
is given you are just given some cost
function f star of Z of how much it
costs to buy certain edges for 42 by a
capacity of see on on each edge so so we
can think of special case one that the
cost is just 0 whenever Z is less than C
and otherwise infinity so this is the
previous setting for example but you
might think that maybe there is some
other function of buying some capacity
and that is not just a zero and then
infinity ok so very very natural problem
and and the nice thing about primal dual
i think is with you see that this is the
same problem and then you can solve both
of them at the same time
and indeed this is what what we are
doing so so this is the original problem
this is the generalization and then what
we can show is that if F is what I call
nice non-negative monotone convex
function and we also need with the
gradient of F is monotone this is quite
technical but so maybe we can get rid of
this assumption but but in all of the
applications we don't we have this
assumption as well then what you look on
some power metal p which is the supremum
of this term which you just tell you the
intuition is that the function is not
two convex so so if you think about this
as a polynomial of the grip even this
will be P idly so it tells you that the
function is not two convex in some sense
and then what we can show is just air
that you can get a competitive ratio for
the covering which is P log D to the P
wear these again the whole sparsity for
the packing you can get p log deal with
a max and a mean as before through the
power of P and and what we can show so
so this matches the best bound for the
linear case but we can show that this
matches a lower bound also for some
polynomial of the grippy so so this is
essentially the best thing that we can
get with with these power metals and we
have many many applications for for this
framework because the nonlinear
objectives were studied in lots of her
and you can take any of the linear
problems and just make it with a
nonlinear objective but for example for
the LP norm set cover we can show how to
round it and getting the same thing that
you get for the linear for the linear
get log deal
okay n n is the number of of elements
but you pay additional p cube over log
people so this is for example but other
applications with scheduling facility
location and many other applications so
just previous result so it's so natural
that people thought about it but way
they thought all or maybe only on the
primal or maybe on the dual and didn't
see the connection so this is one paper
that considered what we call online mix
packing and covering which is
essentially in the language of this
paper minimizing the max out of K
functions with covering constraints so
so very called it mixed covering packing
because you can write this as mean
lambda and then lambda is greater than
each one of these constraints and then
this looks like packing but I think this
is much more natural but this is a
convex function that you try to minimize
so they got something like log K log be
with also a max to a mean and cmax to
see me and in this paper we just clean
the result so we get to just the log K
log D competitive and this is the best
letter that you can hope for also the
the packing a problem was considered
which is the dual so this is another
motivation you can think about
maximizing social welfare with some
production costs so so the problem is
that you have n item types and you have
buyers with a live one after another and
then each buyer has some value to each
bundle of items that you can allocate to
to this buyer so v is is the value of
the
and ls2 if you are located to buy or I
and then ajs is the number of items in
in band LS and then you can think about
variables Y is is to allocate a bundle
s2 to buy a lie and you should do it
online so you should just decide on the
fly if you allocate and which bundle you
are located to buy or i zs is how many
items you need to produce so so you can
write it as you need to allocate at most
one bundle to each buyer and this
constant means that you need to produce
z GJ items of type j and then what we
consider this some production costs for
the items which is very call it f of
course but the I quality in my language
f stove of j of how how much it costs to
produce DJ units of each item but what
you can see is that in this case f star
is what i call separable because the how
much it costs to produce item one is
unrelated to how much it costs to to
produce item two so you can think about
joint cost function where you you can
have cost function different cost
function for any type of items that you
want to that you want to produce so more
general production function in our
framework and okay so I have how much
time
Wow okay everything maybe so i want to
tell you so questions about the model
now i'm going to speak about the
algorithm and the proof great so i'm
going to tell you now that the algorithm
is quite simple and also the proof is
not too complicated which is nice i
think so so what is the algorithm this
is the whole algorithm that we have so
you start from from a solution to the
primal which is zero and solution to the
dual which is zero and now you get a new
constraint and the new duel and then
what you start you start increasing YT
traitor delta and here i hide some this
depends on the power meter of the
problems and how convex the function is
and some other parameters of the problem
but then how I increase the primal so I
take it each XJ that can contribute
something to the current to the current
constraint and update this with with
rate which is a TJ XJ plus 1 over d D is
the sparsity of the constraints over the
gradient the jetta coordinate of the
gradient so you should think about if
it's the linear case it's divided just
by CJ for example and if you think about
it as kind of multiplicative update or
exponential growth and I will show in a
minute area what is the analysis of this
so this is the whole algorithm just
hiding some details about this Delta and
then hiding some other details that I
will tell you in a minute so what we can
show so we take this primal and dwell
and then we can shove it in the dist
algorithm produce it produces a monotone
primal solution right it always
increases and the
not on dual solution because I never
decrease anything that is Otto of p log
D over a max to a min to the pee dee and
that's it from which duality I just get
the result so so this immediately means
with both P and D are that competitive
and this proves the at least the packing
which has the a max to a min in it and
so what is the ingredient of the proof
so the proof is not not too complicated
so with some belief you can believe me
so so here is the update hole in small I
hope you can see just to remind you and
this is in even smaller the primal and
the duel and so now here's one main
observation let's look how much profit
we make and how much cost we have
without this F style for a minute so
what is assumed that YT is increased at
rate 1 and 0 to delta for just for this
line so DF 2 dy t by the chain rule is
just this and then i plug in this rate
he'll and here i put the gradient and
then i get just the sum of all variables
which contribute to my constants of 80
jxj this is less than 1 because the
constraint is still unsatisfied
otherwise I wouldn't increase and this
is less than 1 because this is the
sparsity of the constraint so eventually
I get to here and then if you get back
to the race of whiteys delta then you
get if you take X X hat as the final
solution you just get here with the
profit that you make is at least Delta x
over to the final f of X set right which
which means that essentially if you
increase Delta you make a lot of perfect
which is good but the bad thing is that
you are going to pay a lot of production
costs so there will be some balance here
between the two but but for now if you
if you increase the duel faster you get
more profit and compared to the to the
primal solution so now we only need to
to bound the production costs what I
call the production cost which is this
term so now we hear the main claim so I
claim that the XJ grow quite fast so how
fast it's exponential in the dual
constraint and this is true for any
subset actually now i'm not i'm not
going to use it but in in two slides i'm
going to use it but think about it as
just do all the dual constraints so it's
exponential where with the dual
constraint / the final gradient and
delta and this is minus 1 divided here
by sparsity and the maximum of atj so so
if the duel is fast you should think
about it growing exponentially with the
dual okay five minutes okay so this is
essentially solving differential
equation kind of differential equation
being a bit careful about it using that
the gradient is monotone you can prove
this claim but then we know that x j is
less than 1 over the minimal a TJ
because otherwise XJ alone satisfy all
the constraints so there is no point in
increasing it and then if you plug both
of these you can get with the dual
constraint you can just get it but the
dual constraint is bounded by something
that is related to Delta the gradient
and some logarithmic downhill and then a
right this is you plug this into into
this function f style and then buy some
properties other properties of f star
and the bound on the convexity
you can bound actually bound the
production costs and then you can bound
the production costs as some function of
Delta and the final step is to optimize
Delta this is a this is basically the
whole the whole poof but what i want to
show you last is the idea of how you get
rid of this a max to a min term in the
in the covering so this is a I think we
the nicest idea here so the idea is you
cannot use the D that we already built
because the difference is there with log
da max to a meal and so what we do is
produce a shadow maybe another dual d
prime that removes the same acts to a
min but the this D prime is not monotone
so this D prime you adjust at some point
you will decrease values of of variables
so i want to show you why we must
decrease the dual variable so if you
don't get the rest of it at least you
you get the idea of why we must so here
is a primal covering which is trivial it
has one variable and then you have
constraints X 1 is greater than 1 X 2 is
greater than M X X 1 is greater than M
square and so on and m is very large
number okay so this is quite reveal any
algorithm will just increase the amount
fatigue needs and you will be one
competitive right but when you look at
the do other things so quite different
so so this is the dual you have
maximized y 1 plus m times y2 + m
squared times y 3 and so on right and
you have a dual constraint with some of
why I can be at most one this is the the
dwarfs oh so I'm looking just at the
linear case for now now suppose you aim
for a primal dual algorithm with the
constant competitive ratio see maybe
even not one just the three
or something all right so so what you
have to do after this constant arrive
the value of the optimal solution is one
so you must have a value of the dual
which is one over C so you must set y 1
to 1 over C right and then when the next
constraint arrived the value of the
primal is M so you need the dual to be
at least m oversee the first y will not
contribute my much because m is very
large so essentially you need to set y 2
to 1 over C also right and if you
continue is this you will need to set y
3 2 1 over C and so on but then at some
point of time this constraint is
violated so what you must do is is just
decrease previous dual variables at this
case so I have one minute so maybe i
will say so just the choice of the dwell
which dual variable should be decree so
whenever we get a dual constraint which
is tight what we do is we look for a
previous duel with the largest
coefficient in this constraint and the
crease this at a rate that will make
this duel ok this is this is the whole
idea and this is certainly a greedy
choice maybe not the optimal choice but
certainly a greedy choice and and this
is the rate in which we will decrease
this duel and what we can show is in few
slides if I had some more time is but
this is indeed they're walking and and
you can get you can get enough the dwell
increase enough that you can pay for the
primer cost so just these are the main
results which we have again these are
the main results and some questions so
so first I want to say that maybe d is
not the right power metal hill so like
the whole sparsity is very
it is not a I will find you might have
some better power meter to follow your
problem because what you can do is if
you add some noise to your matrix like
epsilon noise it doesn't change really
the problem but make the sparsity n so
you might want to go with some other
more refined power meter that is not
that if you add such noise will not
change its value so so maybe this is
even in the linear case and then were a
lot of other so many applications with
you can maybe find additional extensions
maybe your possible and uncovering is
something that we walk on and there are
some connections to learning that we
don't understand well so thank you the
primal is still monotone adjust decrease
some dual and then I need to show that
my poor feet from the dual that I
increase currently is not affected much
with other duels that I increase and
these are the three slides that I like
five more minutes okay the interest of
time we can take questions offline tango
three continuity
you